hello welcome to this video I'm doing a
new dual commentary video little mad
[ __ ] two games against own on another
channel my channel that gain guys
challenge Mia thrivent one knife cannot
pronounce said William it's a bit tricky
that name this is the channel or phone
chess expert David luscombe if I'm
pronouncing that correctly probably I'm
not doing that he's got a YouTube
channel as well he's going to do
commentary on these two games as well
i'll put the link in the video
description and something to click on so
you can check out both comments i'll say
ok we're going to play l 3 + 2 3 minute
to second increment and he's pausing at
this please note that the ratings here
are ya not helping you a lot it's not
the five-minute rating it's the ICC
blitz rating that means this is the the
system based on challenges not the auto
pairing the pool system that means it's
entirely different rating pool and
therefore cannot be in any way compared
to what you normally see my writing is
not really adequate and his also and
he's got a very decent five million
rating of 2115 so he also could be a
normal opponent let's say in the one of
the regular Blitzer games so I played
quickly this line in the Slav black is
very solid but he doesn't have as much
of central control as wide has 94 hmm
care probably have to centralize that
bedrock he probably is going to take
them not i'm probably going to force
that soon with 95
pretty typical would be to take on c3
and maybe go for on Bishop a three but I
haven't you see for them the captcha on
xiii also gives me some additional ideas
for developing the bishop to a three or
be too okay I'm canceling this premium
he's taking some time I am ok played it
after all this is interesting now I
cannot go see form have to move the
Queen again question is where maybe all
the way back and be one that cannot be
attacked that easily again yeah I am not
sure about this not sure about the night
position here yeah here I've 95 on a g5
attacking that night and attacking c6
and I've got c4 possibilities in fact c4
is an interesting movie Ender's
pollution already Bishop c4 95 it's kind
of interesting
let's play a simple way c6 is hanging
maybe you can sacrifice it that's an
interesting idea Bishop c4 ok ok I
didn't really have to Bishop g5 on the
radar but interesting IDM if you five
should be five doesn't look very
promising so let's go back and maybe go
for ya so ticking c3m should be too yeah
maybe this
95 maybe mmmm chan he might just take it
now he might just take it if I go 95
kind of annoying okay maybe I can
irritate him a little bit with this he's
got many pieces on the queenside so this
kind of action is so oh really that I
didn't expect okay I'm taking here first
it's useful beginning anyway time
morning yeah I am but ok knighting c-5m
I'll take them and now giving up the
bishop looks I don't know that looks
difficult for black the dark squares
here hmm ok if I co Bishop f4 them to
put on the slow side and c3 is still
kind of weak
hmm still feels right to be active here
and even though c3 at that set is kind
of weak I can actually take and play but
should be five and cover it with this
I'm not happy to have the rook on a one
but the bishop is really strong
see takes deform it's going to be rather
annoying to put it mildly ok so is
giving up giving up the rook them even
though it's not really very tricky
that's actually very tricky let's do a
three maybe you can check me here from
25 it could be a problem an avid c4 hang
so it's not so easy quinte for might be
a good move here check ok ok I think I
have to stop be three so I'm going here
that also threatens route be warned
Queen f2 is no mate that's really
important oops wow I didn't see that one
I hope I'm not losing I really didn't
see Queen a jade that is lucky ok I can
take here now all right check I have no
time though check check check lady who
how our stuff that what stuff really ok
we're going to play a second game now
and after that we need to do some
analysis challenging for a rematch it
was a tough game I really feel like I
lost control there it will certainly
good at one point but hmm very tricky
business ok I've got the starting
rematch challenged let's see what
happens here ok so maybe some Kings
Indian oh that's not very exciting the
London system going for a solid double
IPA kid or set up see one ok so I'm
trying form b5 Bishop c6 Queen B seven
and be 50 it's a that's interesting
ba ya know b5 is going to take twice so
here and now we can go b5 and probably
should go be five it feels solid for
black but maybe I ought to be five and I
can do something with in space yeah
Bishop g5 now along and I take f3 her
light squares do suffern okay let's try
this first maybe he trades himself on d5
Bishop d3 looks better ok this is also
also good so takes ok I'm not so sure
hear that his a b5 porn also can be some
kind of weakness in this position so
then see I really have expected Queen
takes
you
hmm okay
hmm it's tricky tricky business Roxy
form Quincy for is threatening on f7 I
don't really have such a great way to
find dad hmm I don't want to take there
and play d5 give us Bishop more scope
really not
to get 25 this also i don't know if that
Nets much maybe I can do it Queen takes
Queen d5 Quincy a check Bishop f8 don't
see smile more something terrible
happening to me even though it it looks
shaky somewhat
this is I didn't think about this one he
doesn't threaten much here right not
really I go ye five maybe here he cannot
take he has to move then 30-something
seconds this is a sign kind of tricky
tricky with the term situation the night
is hanging now that was one idea here
maybe we can just take the five play
that that end game but I think I might
be able to to win a pawn down
maybe yes I'm tactical approach to that
position that I'm not seeing him you
just yeah that's not working don't see a
really really good solution okay he just
goes back so now i can take your only
six they're only three and go from here
I can still cannot take this really
annoying so let's go there I techie
three
maybe we should f8 next okay let's start
this quickly don't really have lots of
time ninety-five would have been
interesting of course hmm d5 missed that
yeah but I still have d 5 next captures
on d6 don't help him a lot Cham I cannot
really take a bow on c6 this is not
great how to untangle this stuff this is
good now be sure to see 5 it's really
just a pawn check ok this is usually a
draw bra either no it's not such a draw
I mean it's it's something that I can
try and we'll try have their floor was a
bit was a bit too early check do you
know what is going to give give a draw
here that's not realistic so let's see
the King 2 inch for Mamie check
ok so maybe to f4 check check 96 to f4
is the idea trying to get to the pawn
down there are made nitey 693 mate is a
funny funny 125 probably not check mmm
oh no I'm not no I'm winning huh yeah
it's it's always tricky to and defend
white forfeits on time yeah it was it
was tricky I mean this kind of endgame
you can just can continue this is also
why increment chasm has some advantages
over the sudden death time control you
just don't take draw you just play this
out it's just more chess and white can
prove that you can hold a draw or not if
it's just if it is an easy draw you can
hold it with two second increment but as
we see hmm there are still some some
ideas some some some tricks there ok
let's have a look at the games and start
with this one because we still have it
here um yeah it helped felt own equal
for a long time so let's see what
happens so interesting be form takes
takes Queen B 7e I hear why it felt
better to tell better I had the engine
already gives a good solution Lefors it
would move an interesting move after the
b5 why does got d5 and this is kind of
annoying
and like this that was a good
opportunity but he went here again I
felt that this also should be a little
bit better for him and it seemed to be
the case 95 was interesting here that
move engine just wants to play d 5 but I
didn't want to give his Bishop any any
scope so I chokin played here and now I
went Queen c6 me5 mmm so the engine
doesn't like that move nice to take take
efore Queen and d3 Bishop e3 and white
has a slight advantage yeah that's his
pieces are more active so it's kind of
understandable otm here the thing is
swinging towards blacks favor here I
could have gone d5 immediately here and
I saw that too late I'm looking at this
pawn down so after something like that I
can take and to maybe take only three
but say it's not so tricky a business 94
as good also that takes here here Joe ok
d5 gym Queenie 7 was it play it safe
move 92 a strong according to the
computer probably threatening this one
yeah okay but it was just play it safe
as I said txt and now probably something
better as possible king of aid may I
probably can win the porn without
conceding d5 so this is a better move
and check
okay well here I think this was f4 was
premature I'm trading too much stuff
that I think can she find a shiny red
engine I think this is the wrong but
check check not move the night now
mm-hmm oh yeah here you can draw with 93
yeah this is however very difficult for
a human to assess in this limited time
yeah I can't wait what can probably stay
here in most cases in turn tend to make
a draw King g3 and it kind of continues
where this is luis he has to stay
somewhere somehow like like this and
basically do nothing of course I can try
to can try various things but
objectively is probably probably a draw
okay so let's have a look at the first
game just a moment okay I got the first
game loaded let's see what we had here
that was a slob got some tempe there on
the Queen okay it's still kind of a
normal-looking position now the CAPTCHA
bishop is 6 yeah so I didn't really
believe that this is good you too noisy
file but what I overlooked is that after
this um this isn't isn't that that grade
actually I am engine gives Bishop e3 in
this position that's an interesting
choice between a five year okay I wanted
to go for that 95 my gym I think we're
talking about a pretty normal equal kind
of position here with the h5 and now we
played the movie 5 and this is something
I did not expect at all but is given by
a stock fish with 0.5 only
okay I took the engine wants to play age
6 that's the interesting interesting
idea actually I just wanted to have his
King positioned position weakened a
little bit with the pawn trade on g6 but
with h6 of course we have this kind of
porn that can be useful with crece 7mate
hmm yeah that's that's very good
probably okay I didn't get that took him
and now we had this interesting position
yeah and this is this kind of position
is really really difficult to evaluate
and to play because on the one hand
blacks King position is tricky then he's
got no dark squared Bishop anymore and
my bishop as we saw God active but my
queen side is also in very bad shape I
just tried here had to go for some kind
of decision and now Bishop f5 so very
interesting now and the engine wants to
play wiki eight now Bishop to f6 and
rookie six very interesting Bishop
default let's see five and now he five
is the computer line Quincy three look T
1 aha aha for nice little checkmate idea
Bishop t5 now engine gives Queenie 296
and this is check the drawing line that
the engine gives hmm
does this cell is that very forced I
don't know let's say black continues
then I've got I've got this one yeah
this is the thing that that is makes it
so difficult it's a very double-edged
position I have those meeting ideas
there his king is bad but he's got a
pawn and he's got decently coordinated
pieces I mean this is kind of good Andy
line is a default is blocked they are
centralized the computer says equal yeah
it's very difficult to assess form for a
human for human player but engine can
calculate this to a clear clear
conclusion okay make sure also to watch
um to watch David's commentary on that
it's always enjoyable to compare both
them both videos yeah hope you enjoyed
it thanks for watching